[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
is
how are you guys
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
oh
like okay like catchy enough
five
[Music]
here
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
degrees
like
okay
i
alrighty ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the creek in the cave in austin texas
now who's ready for other people of a
dating comedy show give it up for your
hosts this
it's
evening
what the [ __ ] is up austin texas
[Applause]
is
you guys are all celibate
for one minute and then we're going to
interview them afterwards you can sign
up right here
plus tonight which is
um
[Applause]
disappointing your grandparents
i'd like to thank everybody for coming
out for the rehearsal
you know
um
so if anybody's walking around here and
sees a little piece of calamari that's
daddy's
i am not a 6 p.m
well thank you guys thank you guys for
coming
jason is uh on parole so please don't
tell
anyone they saw him here
uh
jason what's uh what's the biggest crime
you've committed
i was uh i spent a long weekend in
canada on a camping trip and i thought
it'd be funny to take off all my clothes
and walk down the highway naked
and uh the police didn't find it as
funny as i did
police the real
humor police to his policemen yeah i
know he grabbed me by the army says
you're under arrest and i said for what
he goes through a decent exposure and
said well i still have my watcher
i'm covered he's not showing his wrist
because he's not a [ __ ]
thank you
i like it when people laugh at the table
at times it's really really nice this
audience is on edge because they might
be in this bucket
they'll go on a date
fantastic let's see how you like it when
no one's laughing at you
yeah
we're gonna have a great time we've got
some straight men and women here let's
start off with the normal
[Music]
uh
blow dryer please
is
[Music]
[Applause]
these kids don't know that reference
the straight woman coming up is jessica
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's really nice
[Music]
so when you move to austin uh march well
i just went four weeks ago yes
new jersey from new jersey
actually that's a lie i actually moved
from boston
economics finance
do you live in downtown or do you live
in the far out
i live at the alexa waterloo
two minutes away from here
are you from college yeah oh [ __ ] my
boy's also gonna like tomorrow i'm sorry
do you actually do that
um
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the newest episode of love on the
spectrum
you guys are fresh out of school
what kind of grades did you guys get
jessica
mike white plays
pretty good ones believe it or not i
believe it deepen
they don't keep those glasses of 2.5 gpa
students
these are the harry potter classics
so deepen uh
how did you like new jersey
new jersey was great as you can tell i
love it there you've mentioned it three
times so far it's a big part of my
personality really really which part i'm
princeton okay
jessica how do you feel about uh being
asked how you feel twice
mike please
i feel like i'm
i'm not from new jersey so
yeah strength number one way to go
jessica you're [ __ ] up already
jessica how uh how do you feel knowing
that he's in equity
what does that mean is that like horse
horse stuff
[Music]
he doesn't have a horse i do not have a
horse that's a horse [ __ ] that he wants
what do you think about dating is it
like
so 20 20 or are you still doing it yeah
we're still doing it oh yeah brother
[Music]
how's the dating pool in austin
it's not bad if i ever i'm not working
but you work a lot with horses right a
lot of horses actually
what are you doing you guys are both in
finance so
that kind of explains the uh
autism
i feel like i was applying for a loan or
something clearly looking at each other
going no
very official days
you guys can cross this off on your i
calendar i've never seen anybody use
academics as like a sword like their
degrees education
we have many universities we don't just
have the university of ottawa
we compete with each other academically
that's where the best country in the
world that's why i have a green card
welcome thank you i'm going to apply for
citizenship this year
is looking at you sexually right now
she's just looking at me going yes the
devil is white
so deepan what do you think about uh
jessica being from indiana what do you
know about indiana can you just spitball
me they don't want to corner anything
that's true right
we have a lot of coin in new jersey
it's all over the place have you been to
the turnpike it's going everywhere
isn't turnpike just your name for a
highway yep
have i been to the turnpike
if there's one use your financial acumen
to figure out
a proper
proper location for corn
um you know corn is cool you know new
jersey most densely populated state in
america so
michelle wants squeezing corn in there
too
poor
ladybug
even your butthole
jason is distracting me
uh usually i have a woman on the show
and
jason is uh not older we'll see
is there a map
oh when i push it back a little bit
[Music]
live on youtube this is being streamed
by the way on youtube i don't know if
you wanted to put anything away
if your [ __ ] is out actually no put it
away no i am wearing shorts
in my 40s so my balls could be at the
bottom
ladies
interesting
this is how dates happen
[Music]
like do you guys like go out for dinner
and talk to people i would take my first
usually i go for the dinner for the
first day
yeah
that's pretty interesting you're locked
in face to face for at least an hour
sitting inches away
doesn't it become
i'm sorry uh jason what do you think
about this wonderful couple
i like them
i don't know if it's actually a couple
there's something there i don't know if
you guys were destined to form some sort
of corporations
immediately
got each other i think we picked up on
him
before he picked up but you just fully
repeated questions welcome to men and
women
yeah no this is a bit of a social
experiment from d2 i don't really go out
during the day i have a very different
it's nocturnal
i i
know it's a different thing for me so
it's nice to be people smiling again
smiling faces
um you guys are uh both
uh like young
professionals
uh did you guys uh
pick up on that or what do you guys
think about each other i picked a lot
yeah
her posture was completely different she
had a very clear
more corporate than me right yeah you
would have jessica looks like the main
character in a lifetime
go to movie
did you get high don't worry
i wish it but
i think you can okay
with me
hold on
how do you say your name perfectly
what's the funniest situation you've
been because your name is a verb
this is what you're asking karate
comes out comes up surprisingly a lot
and i'm always on edge because of that
you're always
close to getting deepened
[Music]
deep
something that you don't want your
friends to hear
have you ever been deep sea diving
no no
i'll tell you that it's fitting right
does anyone ever say deep in that was
deep
it's rude
jessica has anyone made a joke about
your name
why do you always forget the life just
pretend you're in indiana studying
something
poor
jesus
drunk
so uh who did you come here with your
friends i did
who are they what do they do
because they all look like they have
401ks
do they all work in finance with you no
what's the worst job that someone here
had everyone looked at the black guy
that was racist
he could be a professional for all we
know
professional
dixon
[Music]
that's a racist one too
calvin and corn on the cob
we're here with jessica
the master of corn
any other uh indiana related questions
nice
that's why she's here
the second
third most corn corns estate in the
union
jason what do you think about the this
couple
they're very interesting i don't know
they want to take them for myself both
of them
what did you do with them i don't know
like you changing the things
no
well how boring
must be one of those pilgrims from
boston
jessica uh
how did you date in college what was
your dating life like were you in a
sorority or do you just look like that
surprise surprise
david i know you were in the uh math
club so
i guess
it wasn't imagination that way
what did you learn in math club besides
how to not talk to girls horses
apparently
courses
what do you do now with your equity
degree
uh
what company have you bought
um you buy video game companies so
company called behavior interactive
nature they need to be involved
[Music]
never
getting the [ __ ]
how long you've been uh single though
uh six months six months yeah what was
uh your longest relationship two and a
half years wow did you live together for
your period of time no
no it says in college that's a big
commitment when you move into somebody
you look at every day it gets closer to
that at least ending so you can get the
[ __ ] out of that
is from a country
so i don't with arranged
he can't relate it's like that bollywood
superman i love it
just take off the glasses and do this
uh jessica so uh what was your longest
relationship
um
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's why he's sick like the
bastard
uh he's already buying it's hard to tell
your skin is beautiful i can't wait to
see the evidence bag
i don't know
26
over 30.
no why don't you just tell them
um
that was really close
uh anyways how old are you
twenty-eight wow okay twins in your
family
[Laughter]
where would you take her
there's a really good restaurant called
the well
[Music]
i know how these finance types work yeah
yeah i don't know
i can clearly have my elevator here
all you people have degrees in hopes
no
what about babies
jessica is there anything you'd like to
ask our resident uh dating expert jason
announced right now
you don't want to know anything inside
his
scaly scaly head
is this your looking just like my father
has a gun
[Music]
winter summer
winter
during your five and a half long
relationship
we gave you canadians
that's funny
afterwards
i'm very racist
really
what was his name
for toronto
[Music]
yeah i agree with you
um anyways
anything we want to do to like woo
jessica your
six-year senior
italian food are you italian
oh okay
no way it's perfect it's crazy yeah
you're full i mean
let's just ruin all the progress our
parents made
is it your mom that's the white or the
your dad's the wife
mom's white nice [ __ ] white women
good job on your dad
[Music]
no way
these two finance majors are just lying
their asses off
[Music]
is
what do you think she's half indian he's
indian
what do you think's gonna happen with
this
three quarters of the nicu i think
they're gonna start a successful
business together but there's definitely
going to be no able that's for sure
no anal in your future
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hopefully you guys are all lesbians
we got keys coming up
okay we'll save you for later you're
coming up next buddy
don't cancel us
uh shelby is the woman's name
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i just turned 32 um two weekends ago
obviously you know that cause i'm on dio
yeah i love it i'm contourious i don't
know much is it wet that we're we're
sisters
you hold things really
[Music]
but people in this community usually get
me so i'm just like
shelby
okay
please take
[Music]
yeah they they moved from
zero to
uh home run real quick
but you know how those lesbians are with
softball
and she's 55 she told me the rule is the
second date is moving in with lesbians
nice you guys all have the uh
subaru for the job too
anyways yeah what about that that was
quite a funny thing yeah i was uh
i don't see people click up so quickly
and just like i didn't smell any
[ __ ]
there's no [ __ ]
for you
yeah compared to that straight thing
that we saw earlier
they're not touching each other uh
they're actually
jessica actually filed a restraining
order
so how many uh women have you dated uh
versus men is it like 50 50 uh shelby or
is it more like 70 30.
men are just easier
hey
we're the easiest
what's up america that's the 70
yeah and then women
not binary
i'm non-binary so
okay
i know what that means
and i approve it
but that's important
uh yeah the nine binary women are the
thirty percent yes
what about binary one where you just
don't like them
[Music]
um
[Music]
where do you guys fight when do you guys
accuse each other of racism
does that ever happen no it doesn't
matter so have you ever slept with uh
your boyfriend and another woman before
and uh you you've done that multiple
times
you're trying to make an effort yeah
it's like we try to slow it down
maybe five days
and how does it usually five days during
the week jesus christ i
you need to be really flexible mobile
you do yoga
why are you looking at me i'm a dude
oh you have to be you have to be that
agile too otherwise you can't [ __ ]
ultimately yeah
okay
you gotta exercise your accomplished
work right you weirdo
i got called a weirdo by jason
what do you think about this couple do
you think that they have a future i was
just jealous over the communication
right off the break it was i was
like watching your faces from doing
comedy for so long
how
genuine the connection is and it was
just like you guys just tossed a ball of
positivity back and forth
it was cool
yeah it's not cesare
sounds like my cousin's name
that was a great beautiful assessment
jason a seasoned vet canadian you know
just for laughs on tv all that
you guys uh you guys have anything that
you'd like to ask jason right now maybe
about you know
skin care budget your boyfriend's
licking his lips no
[Music]
okay um what is your favorite part
[Music]
you know
usually when i got my green card 15
years ago was maybe today with the same
dude
this was kind of a
semi day off of work so i was trying to
this is like casual around the house for
me got it i just noticed that you had
them on and then all of a sudden they
weren't silver anymore yeah
[Music]
[Music]
weird enough balance i think this is uh
the freaking the geek right now yeah
there's a show in here somewhere how
about good cop
is that a city in vietnam no but i think
i don't know if you're that believable
at the police officer
yeah i don't know if you can try but i
can't
i've never had driver's license
no way ever canadian uh
public lands trading needs okay do you
guys think we're gonna make it
i think yeah audience kind of voted
please uh you brought up your sign and
then when shelby brought up her side
you're like oh actually i don't know
anything about astrology yeah actually i
just know a little bit but i just i just
people trust what are you saying when
you look at me yeah yeah so
somewhere true yeah i think so they give
me a pass
but that's why i try not to do like get
into it
no
no no they want you to get into it yeah
i'm very american that's cool i love
america yeah america likes to subscribe
to a lot of stereotypes no it means the
actual land have you have you ever been
a road trip um
i've been to 25 countries but to be
honest with you i didn't make two states
when i moved here was the beginning of
depression and anger sensitivity so i
hid out of the place i could talk for
you to choose the state of texas
please how high are you
um i don't know which i took maybe
that's a lot for me
um
so your eyes aren't usually asian no
they're oily
they don't know any bigger than that
that's wonderful
i'm glad you are honest and up front
during this date you were like i'm an
altered state of consciousness i wish
jason had done the same thing for the
show tonight
jason are you on any drugs
[Music]
lovely ladies people trying to make
these love connections i know this isn't
it looks like it's a game struggle
people are clearly here to meet somebody
right
don't be ashamed
it's a show in canada though it's in the
80s
i auditioned for that show with drake
actually
drug dealer
he's justin bieber's godfather
i remember dragging his mother sitting
there
before i had a small part but they said
they were it was the reboot of the
original degrassi and drake played that
he was in a wheelchair
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh justin bieber
brian adams
shelby are you do you do drugs at all
[Music]
uh what drugs do you do besides changing
your butter oil
um
no but i did get both of
i was them at what age yeah i was 21. no
they held three years uh 50 and 48.
my roommate is older than my parents and
she's my best friend that's all right
uh do you live with an old roommate
she's a 56 year old lesbian she's my
best friend and her girlfriend works
with us as well can you see her wet
coveralls
does she wear coveralls
um
you recently got um for everyone that
lives in the house
it's a tarpon
what do you guys do in
these um
watch me connor
[Music]
and where does the wand go
that's none of my business i got a
couple boyfriends
that are over during this time she has
her girlfriend
what kind of snack food you have when
you guys are watching harry potter
a lot of ice cream i love ice cream but
we always say ice cream in the dead
girls
[Music]
that's true
yes
uh have you ever worn a movement before
yeah i'm from hawaii
nice
and what is yours this was actually a
moon and i turned it into this oh you
made that yourself no
you work in finance by chance
uh keys what are you uh what do you like
to do with your boyfriend besides [ __ ]
other women
[Music]
hey calm down
we love to travel
we love to
take road trips like long ones to like
montana
we just got back from montana and
actually it was so beautiful
so you love america i love america i saw
four grizzly bears on my birthday do you
know how rare that is
that's kind of scary she's like i live
with one
you guys should check out and i know
they do events in
the company from dallas
is called torture guard it sounds very
sinister and stuff but just google
tg.com
and you'll uh
you'll see the other side of things
[Music]
it has like different rooms with various
you guys can travel to it it was wild
two birds one stuff super sexy super
sexy i see all the ones in london i had
a [ __ ] on the dance floor while i
watched a fetish and show i was
like i mean the lesbians are all
together in safety
[Music]
that's really dating
around the band
especially like i said
go to europe and
this kind of process is very kind of
square to me for the traditional sense
of dating and people being you don't
date at all you go to other countries
again i was in amsterdam this summer
yeah that's for disneyland for perverts
no it's very touristy you know you look
in there's like families there ice cream
you walk in the canals so what do you
think about this lesbian couple you
think that uh they're better than
straight couples or
i i'm just impressed on you know we've
already prepared two couples yeah
straight people get your [ __ ] together
yeah you're embarrassing us
[Music]
they seem like they're very happy
until one of them leaves a dish in the
sink
and then someone like supposed to know
and it involves
[Music]
[Music]
well uh thank you so much for coming out
and dating each other
[Music]
[Music]
another gay
[Applause]
[Music]
and don't forget you can sign up anytime
he is already planning her threesome
with her boyfriend right
get up for her
current and
dayton go on a date for one minute
how long have you been downtown
[Music]
um
this is my friend
calvin
did you get to drive before you decided
to do here did i get to drive yeah drive
around town uh
yeah
yeah okay why are you still here well
that's a great question i go to school
and georgetown okay i mean
okay cool so that's it i mean i'm on
track
um
well i mean i'm awesome
so
this is like a day between dracula and
frankenstein
kill someone
what kind of boring gay person are you
dude well i mean
it's overcrowded or something
oh yeah
how much you remember parties
yeah
this looks like a scene from call me by
her name right now
uh are you way uh older than uh this
college student dayton
uh probably not
holy [ __ ] you guys are both the same age
why is everyone so young here 23
22.
holy [ __ ]
make that degrassi reference again see
if they get it
nope
[Applause]
so what's it like here how's the fourth
street doing
can't find parking
parking except for your talk
exactly
uh well the whole gay community of
austin is here tonight apparently just
two of them
uh
what's up what events are
here you know i know tuesdays is right
around the corner from here where the
game's going to say
[Music]
work
we're being gentrified right now
the stage is now 500
a week
uh but yeah you guys uh come from where
do you guys come from okay
dallas okay
i moved here from atlanta just outside
of atlanta nice where we're outside of
atlanta uh it's called kennesaw
in a stop there's a school there so
that's why okay
hi
anyways uh
kennesaw native
and the dallas
that was
what kind of diagnosis could you be
[Music]
he's not afraid
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i'm working on
in this relationship
i felt that when you sat down
to him but you were opening your chest
we were like i was going to give a
chance but as he talked that kind of
appreciated
and
became edward sullivan
[Music]
[Music]
uh current
uh so if you came with your friends
jessica among them
the guy that raised this guy
yeah i met most of them today but uh
yeah nice well how did you meet that
um they lived in the same apartment as
uh as me i just moved in with calvin
they're friendly you know in the races
yeah
where did you move from atlanta georgia
south
[Music]
yeah i would say austin is a friend of
mercy yeah right
lady waved me a bicycle yesterday
she was flagging you down
no i think she was turning the cops
across the street
what uh what did you want it's just like
a friendly halloween
with an eye
they don't do that in canada no i think
it's all very
passive aggressive it's the all these
stories have to wait because we've seen
that diarrhea
in canada if they pass each other and
they go sorry
yeah these are the stories
south park really
disrupted the country
everyone thinks our heads flop around
the top of our backs
yeah you guys are uh you guys are our
northern mexicans yeah they call
snowbacks
hell yeah
luckily
not a lot of mexicans tonight
um
so dallas yeah
how's
what is your uh have you ever dated a
mexican before
if you hated mexico
okay
have you ever dated a hispanic
no
damn it oh you guys are only 22.
uh huh what's the longest relationship
you've been in oh you're half
nice that's healthy how white was this
person
uh
just quiet
it's like two solar panels
[Music]
how did you guys meet
uh we met on
tinder
tender
surprise it's not grinder you guys still
use tinder
yeah we try to it's it's the better one
of the two in my opinion is it
is it an algorithmic thing do you have
more luck
oh no just on tinder not every single
person is trying to
[ __ ] each other
yeah i hate that you like small talk
in a relationship with substance with
somebody you generally care about
hey you guys want to come over and play
stratego
do you find this to be the case you're
trying to continue to be better spot on
uh tinder is like you know that's that's
if you're looking for something that's
not just a disgusting workout no that's
like the degrassi of dating apps
are you guys consider yourself kind of
conservative daters
clearly from leaving one app to
something a little more not so sexually
hostile
what are you talking about yeah okay i
didn't know you could use both what do
you mean
you're done with two hours why would you
that's a lot of your time occupied to
try to become i'm trying to figure i i
got two like this
right and one one service is
jason is uh
really a practical man you know he knows
what he wants
and he knows how to tell us about it
[Laughter]
if anyone
wants a monster wants some jason seaman
are you dating somebody
not really no this is difficult to uh do
this and uh have a relationship because
you're going wrong for long periods of
time and
then she sucks off all of your friends
okay
that is my worst nightmare
have you guys ever been cheated on
you guys are gay so yes
[Music]
have you continued a relationship when
you kind of had an internal revelation
that this person was being deceptive yet
you stayed in it because it was too
painful to leave
disrespectful relationship
this is a hallmark channel
[Music]
promo right now
uh
david what's the uh
what's the weirdest thing that's
happened to you in a relationship
oh man okay uh one time i got picked up
by this guy's mom for a date was like
17. right yeah she's like hey do your
parents typically know that like you go
on dates and strangers and monks picks
you up he's like that's pretty business
but um
but like also at the same time
while she's picking up with her kid in
the car all right
and then so you guys are going on a date
in the back seat of the suburban no the
date was gonna be to his uh aunt's house
i think that's what it
happens if you was car based
infrastructure there's no public transit
yeah no amen to that if you go to like
paris you know
they started [ __ ] the subway over
there
you did a good job on your makeup thank
you
well
uh
it's coming into
yeah it's very clean
people are uh you know taken care of
they have very good health systems to do
about a
sense of immortality
[Music]
you guys are both sitting there with
your seatbelts on oh yeah this is like
the first time
[Music]
each other's cogs
[Music]
uh walmart and she's home all right
she's really hungry and so she's hungry
enough to pull some donuts off the shelf
open the back and start peeking yeah she
has not paid yet
right right i'm like who the hell did i
just get this car with and um you know
it ended up being totally fine i'm gonna
have like donuts in
just opens the weeds
of donuts in a walnut and starts eating
them as they shop then you have the
luxury of uh uber where you could just
subject yourself from the date and scam
check
for me i wish i had known about that
yeah
it was actually a better dating app than
tinker for a small talk
[Music]
you're not mom yeah anyways give it up
for a koran adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
we got some more straight men and
straight women
back to the bread and butter of the show
let's get the feedback a little
a little not feedbacky
let's pick the woman first
uh we got [ __ ]
meanwhile kinda rhymes with frida
elam yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
happy
[Music]
oh it was wonderful
[Music]
well i have birthdays tomorrow so thank
you
we uh we went to
marbles on the immortal um
it's like
evening we crashed a gala for big
brothers and sisters
um and somehow like managed to get some
free drinks in the afternoon
oh sure yeah how about you i went to the
jack johnson concert
i i wanted to do that i saw that i
depended on my calendar how was it it
was good um really chill time and it
went for our friend's birthday so oh
cool it's a good birthday weekend for
people what other music do you like to
listen to uh i was gonna have a little
bit of being my spotify players very
eclectic um but anything from like early
big gaming swing to moderate
yeah nobody um really anything um
so what's your favorite jack johnson
song
banana pancakes
very efficient dates
a lot of information was exchanged
about two terabytes per second
uh matthew do you work in finance i do
not
no well you should talk to deepak
do you go on a lot of dates in austin or
are you mostly
not yet i'm also kind of a new
transatlantic oh hell yeah so many new
people here where are you from
uh i'm originally from little rock but
most recently from brooklyn
arkansas
and now you're you're from brooklyn
you ever seen an asian in little rock
he's actually really good uh indian
community asian community yeah
surprises people only five of them from
wisconsin
hell yeah
is there a lot of asians in wisconsin
so you are the asian yes you're in
charge of dry cleaning and chinese food
well a lot of hats this guy
not just the nice house
uh
matthew what do you think about austin
is it uh you know is it a good hunt
[Music]
it's good and you're in three and a half
years um
wow before the pandemic yeah okay
uh what did you what did you think about
austin uh now how has it changed
uh the city's growing a lot with the
construction and stuff like that joe
rogan and elon
yes i saw your mother
the guy was worried he said
there's some of the locals are not
really happy with this uh invasion yeah
it would suck if you're just huddling
around in austin not doing anything with
your life
how do you like austin for dating is
there anywhere you would like to take
caleb
he sticks really good so like these
sides uh east side
like not dirty here but
hey
[Music]
uh yeah e6 have you ever with the e6
neon
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah i mean uh yeah
36 is pretty pretty pretty gross
disaster to happen
you sleep on someone's shoe a couple of
times it kind of takes the
rudolph the evening
have you ever uh stepped in horseshit on
6th street
[Music]
what the [ __ ] do you do
i work in strategy for a tech company
what an ass i am
what do you do on these six
oh lefties is one of my favorite bars
okay
like really good frozen mars and paint
killers yeah
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
congratulations
i'm in sales can you tell
don't you try to sell matthew some some
drugs right now
curse mother
she says
well if she needs weight loss and
animals you control
them all right
[Music]
no actually no i this is actually not
true it's my mom's fault
but uh
this is probably some of the couples
that start dating is probably a question
that's always on the table it's like
what hereditary diseases are in the
event what
am i my our offspring like ignored like
i don't think they're related at all
but if they had a child together
heart disease
[Music]
yourself luckily you have a lot of drugs
at your disposal
matthew uh what do you think cancer and
autoimmune
that's right it's a good sound you know
it's all right but you've got
uh high blood pressure and diabetes
jason strikes again
like a viper
so i mean are you interested she sells
diabetes medicine or runs maybe you
should stock up before the big uh
these two need like about three drinks
each and then i think that's a level
four level playing field to start this
is a completely sterile awkward
situation but i think there's a few
cocktails why don't you guys just start
making out right now
[Music]
as sterile as her jokes whoa
[Music]
i'm glad we both dressed up for this but
we're short
i think you guys should drink a lot i
think uh eva would get uh you know
less smiling
and matthew would get less autistic
yeah she needs to dull it down and he
needs to develop the personality
i don't have tattoos
whoa
these are these are birthmarks and stop
mocking the color of my skin
blowing out the race card
let's see if this white man can pull it
off
uh
matthew
uh
how's wisconsin for you being asian here
it's all right
we
harley davidson cheese aaron rodgers
a lot of corn like in indiana
or new jersey
you know what's going on
uh that's cool you know barley you know
you guys are drinking a lot you drink a
lot uh yes
[Music]
sometimes i do it when i'm sleeping too
[Music]
[Music]
what do you like to do on dates are you
more like uh you know
you got book clubs
no i i prefer like a good activity like
dinner is always fun but you can kind of
like do something out of the box that's
a little
let me introduce
[Music]
then what have you noticed about white
women
we
[Music]
what's the what's your most favorite
media quality in whitewater
they're very tenacious
it means you guys are [ __ ]
i didn't say that
you're tenaciously
i was just thinking what are the odds
you have another half white half indian
girl up here on stage hell yeah
there's a billion of these
so you guys don't know each other
was your dad white gray wrong way
my mom's
toronto
[Music]
yeah
there's a lot of good food there look at
what what'd you say
[Music]
oh this is
lefties is like a themed
bar
no that's like a patio and like there's
an indoor park but yeah it's a good
uh time kinds just mainstream this is
your daily store
there is no dancing
they do tourbillon tuesdays i will not
go there
never
[Applause]
uh we got a couple more names let's see
how many we can get through we got
it
look
we got a lot coming up i'm gonna high
five to his half indian friend
surprised
lt and
she's got great signals she's got ltg
uh and
one minute starting now
hey lte how's it going
how are you good who convinced you to
come up here
shelby actually and she came up too
i don't know if you'll remember her and
she had a good time
um
[Music]
no no it's my first time here
i just
have a rich family
you know what that's the best lunch
[Music]
well okay you gotta shake it up on
sundays yeah that's why you're here
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
tax brackets and age
brackets that's the best
rook thank you for joining us peasants
tonight
from
your home in the west hills
how's uh how's life being rich whenever
you bought me that would surprise us
he's just bought this entire club right
now out of anger
lt have you ever uh dated a really rich
guy before
no
have you ever dated a guy that looks
like the bad guy in every 90s
i don't know what you said but it sounds
like we're all gonna get arrested
how do you know shelby are you uh a
bisexual as well
no actually your roommates are best
friends
you're the lesbians that she was talking
about
since then now i'm living in austin what
did you think about her lesbian
roommates they're
yeah they're really nice really sweet
always a good time always watching harry
potter
pajamas to wear
what do you think you uh you out here
dating a lot flashing your money around
on brady street i'm not really
what do you do honestly besides
just re-terrorize skateboarding
check out the trails
come to comedy shows
do you like to come to comedy shows
thanks man it's a good show too okay i'm
glad you're not gonna kill us well
we didn't go there yet right yeah
do you have a little brothers you have
an older brother
like four years older close in age yeah
i'm getting to the root of the problem
here
rook is going to be crying in jason's
arm soon
i got a wonderful figure
uh so you go to a lot of comedy shows is
there anything like uh that you'd like
to tell l t right now that would like
maybe
you know get her interested in watching
your comedy
no i don't want comedy okay well let's
grab that though he performs confidence
oh yeah
what do you what do you like to do
confidently
confident yeah
i uh i'm not as confident as you think
i'd like to do comedy sometimes
okay first doesn't it take more
confidence to do it
no i'm terrified right now
[Music]
i feel like i wanted to do an ikea
showroom
you're never getting out
no you should do comedy
welcome to austin uh
please
don't say anything mean about joe rogan
i'm legally obligated to report you
[Music]
uh ella have you ever been a fan of
comedy before lt
yeah
yeah
it's like the magazine e-l-l-e and
then the last
[Music]
[Music]
like no lieutenant
has anyone ever called you lieutenant
before no it's actually short for
gabrielle
what a hell
[Music]
you're you're a fan of tony uh would you
like to tell rook a joke
[Music]
that's why it's gonna be funny
all right why is cinderella terrible at
soccer
she has a big feet
no she runs away from the wall
that made sense
that was a logical thought uh did you
see it on tick-tock or
no
i love some of those like these are like
kid jokes
when you're
nine years old
oh you read it
yeah
uh so yeah what do you think do you
think ruth has a good sense of humor
[Music]
start
he's always got a frown on his face
excellent sense of humor
what's like the funniest thing that
you've done recently
funniest thing i've done which is pretty
funny you know i've decided that we're
watching right now yeah something that
we haven't been a part of oh i got deep
in the come on stage
getting bullied
it's
pretty much similar to that
passports
he's canadian he's got international
jokes
uh anything you like to say to al right
now
yeah it's just nice thanks for really
good support coming up volunteering
and al what agency would you like to
report this game
casting coach
[Music]
thank you so much
and uh
see you on tick tock
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
like the brightest
with
starting now
[Music]
so you're looking i can protect and
provide
what do you do
i work attention
so i make good money i can protect and
provide
20 years
huh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
couple
[Applause]
uh detonating his uh
suicide best
[Music]
you can protect and provide uh what
what's your favorite method of
protection
hello
everybody what do you work out
[Music]
[Music]
i'm also an army officer so i can
protect myself
[Applause]
yeah
you used to be an army officer
so you were shooting people
he works in cyber security and his name
is abdul so i know
he's one of the good
what are you ones in the army i'm a
medical officer
okay so you're uh am i a medic i'm not
the team leader
up
um
so what would you say if abdul was one
of your uh privates and he was like i'd
make more than you
i said i'm sure you do sweet
i don't want to say right now
and then what would you make of go to
finger
[Music]
what do you have to say to selfie joy
maybe like
no i i think at first glance she looked
like you know like typical
princess pretty
nice little girl but then you know i saw
her
i mean son
are you like the syrian andrew tate
pretty much yeah yeah
you know i saw you you were typical
whatever whatever but then i was like
wow that's like you're actually he said
you look sweet but then i realized you
were like basically oh no no uh not a
bad way
like
yeah
like you didn't let me give you [ __ ] you
like you know you said no [ __ ] you
oh
is that what you look for
uh well anyways what uh what do you
think sophie uh you know you asked about
his base salary your uh
salary uh
we can we can discuss that in private if
you really want to see
what we'll find
you know the lingo you know
did i also work in tech it wasn't
[ __ ] awesome what are you doing tech
i do
selling song tech
but uh what what do you
guys so that's on the
[Music]
okay well hopefully you'll never have to
go to syria
um what do you what do you sell
do you want like my whole
company yeah there's a lot of like
software
basically you sell the software that
helps
developers scale their
service from like 10 to 1000
so
we have four open source projects and
then we have an actual product itself
um if you know what
our virtual cluster is
it's not just
a location basically just help software
developers okay and uh
would you like to mansplain your job to
her right now
the job sounds kind of easy but
he's going all in on this i mean he's
feeding me that so you know
i'm sorry
i work for one of them like someone said
that i'll probably get fired okay and uh
how do you protect
protect in what way
like cyber security um so my job is
pretty much as it's in response to
anytime
my company gets hacked or attacked they
call me in technical high schools do you
ever provide for your company or just
protect
you provide advertisements okay wow
yeah
where did you go to school
dallas
dallas
yeah i went to the great valley
i know i just wasn't gonna say
that's where he bought his confidence
from uh
abdul what are you uh what do you think
about sophie would you like to take her
out of the day to east austin maybe
lefties
uh i'm more of a nature guy so you want
to take a walk and talk
you know
yeah
[Music]
direct
my dad actually moved here and he's 18
and he won the lottery
jason rouse just had to suck off a
customs agent
you should do
i have that customization
[Music]
uh sophie uh anything you want to say
about google maybe some helpful helpful
advice for the next lady
nice to meet you
joy would you have to fix the handshake
she's showing me how to shape
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful beautiful man
from syria
well that was the show that was uh
nickelodeon's soapy joy
and al jazeera's
update
jason what'd you think about the dates
tonight what a bunch of sexual attention
they're still in there like
it was complete
it was an odd day
yeah dates it was like a
point system
back and forth
who do you think won the most points by
the lesbians
[Music]
just
cutting us off
[Music]
[ __ ] for dudes she had to deal with
a number of i thought she was going to
shoot him yeah i thought he was going to
get shot too
well you can check out jason rouse on
all social media he is a very very funny
comedian please check him out you can
catch him at the death squad show on
thursday
[Applause]